Film Courage: What has making ECCO movie taught
you about yourself and filmmaking, yourself first,
then filmmaking? Ben Medina, Writer/Director: I
think it was the longest project I've ever done
in my life so I mean definitely
I don't look at schooling as a project
because it changes every quarter so to speak.
It was this competition that
came out in me with myself
and it was shattering a lot of naiveté about how
hard this would be. You have to have some very
challenging internal conversations with yourself
when you get disheartened or when you feel alone
in a process even if you have a great support
network. It's very easy to just shut off it
there's there were rises and falls of depression
that were uncontrollable because you just
get so exhausted with the process. It taught me
how to stop also inside of my myopic obsessive
nature to finish or to get a moment perfect. It
taught me to stop to enough is enough for a day
like if we're cutting we've been cutting for like
12 hours or something it's like stop take a break
and i didn't know that about myself you know um
taught me a lot about health and taking care of
yourself before the shoot during and afterward
because you can you can burn out before you start
shooting you can burn out pre-production and then
you get into production and you're making the most
important decisions about a performance or about
coverage or about a particular moment that matters
and you don't have the battery power to keep
going and that didn't really happen to me but
i could feel it a couple of times where i was like
i am so tired and i wasn't prepared for how tired
my brain was going to be and in the end of the day
i think it taught me that um no one gives you
anything when you get to the top of the mountain
like no one gives you a trophy or uh
like a reward or a bottle of champagne and formula
one race or whatnot you're you usually get to the
top of that mountain in the dark alone and you
have to figure out that that is what you want
it all you know i think at the beginning it
can be really romantic that when you finish
it's gonna you're gonna run through
a ribbon in a marathon or something
but it's a lot closer to what i've read about
some mountaineering expeditions or some summiting
of some peaks where a climber got somewhere
in the dark alone and no one was there and
you have to figure out what got you there you know
a lot of people on the way giving you
support a lot of people in the way
um giving you nourishment a lot of people in the
way helping you know you didn't get there alone
but sometimes you do land there alone you finish
alone um and and then i think i also learned that
the affair is over you know i think that before
you make a movie there's an affair it's like a
romanticized idea of the work and of um um every
part of the process you know people think editing
is easy it's the opposite you know people think
that doing sound mix is easy it's the opposite
um people think they can kind of get away with
doing a di on like um you know their computer
i don't agree with that um and so what happened
also for me was learning that the love affair with
the idea of making a film was dead and for a
little while it wasn't replaced with anything
it was just over and that
didn't mean i wanted to stop
doing this it meant that there was an internal
feeling of emptiness and truth and at the end
of that there was a real strong light at the
tunnel and there was uh like a maybe a mature um
maybe a stronger sensibility of what this really
takes to do and so then when i looked at my next
project i looked at what needed to be fixed i
looked at how the script needed to be polished
and reworked i looked at the production
schedule i immediately pushed production
off by a certain amount i needed more time to do
this right and so i suddenly came at the sophomore
film the next film i suddenly came at that film
with a sense of um realism not optimism and
love and not lust you know and um one of the
things i also learned was that i have a very
um incredible wife you know and
our relationship went from you know
having lots of passion and having lots
of lust and just being so in love with
each other and then when we got married it
became complicated and super interesting
and better and richer and and the fabric of
everything became stronger and is very synonymous
with my breath my metaphor about the affair of
making a movie is over and it becomes better and
more interesting i don't think you can rush that
because i went through a lot of pain to go from
feeling the affair to being in love with this
craft more than i ever have but i had to go
through all of the darkness first and not pretend
like i had done it before i think some filmmakers
including myself years ago maybe had a sense of
feeling like i could do it and it wouldn't be hard
and it's a different journey so i
learned how to tell myself the truth more
yeah i don't remember the other question wow
i don't know if if it can top that i'm just
what did um making echo teach you about filmmaking
oh yeah sure sure uh what did echo what did
making echo teach me about filmmaking yeah um
it was a opportunity to see
strengths and weaknesses
under a microscope right these are
the things i thought i was good at
these are the things i think i needed to work on
and when you take the duration of your material
and when you take the audience's investment in
the material right okay so they were going to be
invested in a 30-second ad or 60-second ad or what
have you right okay so how much of that day is
it taking how much are they invested in watching
this content okay so that's what that is and then
over here it's like they're gonna buy a ticket to
your movie and give you two hours of their life
in a place that's not in their house and
that is a completely different invitation
so it taught me a lot about the reality of okay
this muscle this strength is solid this is good i
can keep improving that and i'm going to challenge
myself to do that on the next movie and here's how
and then the the opposite is true which is i feel
like this aspect of the story or the script needed
work and it never got the right amount of work and
[ __ ] it pisses me off but it didn't and it got
finished and it's done so it's like you can noodle
with it forever and you never ever finish it or
you finish it and you say i gotta really be honest
with myself about that's gotta get fixed next time
it taught me a lot about as a as a
director it taught me a lot about people
taught me a lot about expectations and morale
i was reminded just before the save my ass by
the way i was reminded just before we started
filming like a week before uh my dad says you're
the captain of the ship and i was like of course
you know like thank you and he goes i didn't mean
it like that i meant it like you're the captain
of the ship you are the captain of the ship
things go right you're the captain of the ship if
things go wrong you're the captain of the ship and
after four or five days um it became
super clear that i needed to adapt
my leadership style to the team not
because they needed me to or asked me
to but because i was paying attention to being
the captain of the ship and whether that was to
make sure to every day in the morning say
good morning to every person on the team
and at the end of the day tell every person
on a team great day which i did do and i had
already really been doing that but it wasn't
hyper diligent it wasn't as focused around you
know what they're working so hard every day and
we're only 20 in or 15 or whatever it was and
okay great so that i needed i needed to be a
better leader and um and then it also uh taught me
a lot about um editorial i learned that i'm used
to assembling and cutting while i'm going on ads
and we didn't have that strategy on this film and
we are changing it on the next film so for example
we shoot uh you know we shoot
material i look at some dailies
but i don't make editorial decisions
the editor's not on set working
and then when we're done and we're in the can i
look at everything for a period of four weeks or
whatever and then we start assembling i learned
that that process was super inefficient and the
results of that process was that or the reason why
it happened was because we were working so fast
and so hard every day there wasn't time to review
material in earnest and so that's going to change
on the next film and the next film we're
going to cut concurrently with the production
i read a lot about how that's done i talked to a
bunch of editors in hollywood about how they do it
i followed the process or you know really
drilled in on the process the way they cut munich
uh spielberg's film uh they they cut it
concurrently and they were able to have a strong
assembly of the cut within i believe a few
weeks after production and it also creates an
efficiency in any pickups etc so probably one of
the biggest lessons i learned was about editorial
and the last thing i really really learned about
was my passion for meticulous cinematography
and very specific color grade work in the di is
equal to my level of passion for sound design in
the mix you know i had had a lot of experience in
a di for commercials but the mix on commercials
is really quick they do it in a day it's done
you're not even usually there and on a film the
mix along with foley and design and dialogue
cleanup and looping and stuff you know this
takes months and months to do and i fell in love
with the sound design process i fell in love with
uh the final mix making this weighted ratio
decisions on the audience's experience from
a sound perspective and that was i've never had
that experience before so that was really exciting
so um yeah i'm sure my answer to this
question could be like two hours long
you